audrey starco would never have guessed
that one day her work clothes would look
like this
she grew up in ghana's capital accra and
studied business administration now she
lives and works in the countryside
good morning good morning
how are you doing
it's been an amazing journey but one
that has been a roller coaster as well
and our journey started about four years
ago
where i came here
as a researcher and also as a tourist
just
in the hopes of finding more about
what sugarcane is all about
what are the benefits of it for
communities within ghana
sugarcane is a major crop in the
southeastern volta region and it's here
that audrey starco has set up a small
production facility for organic
fertilizer that's okay the chief
component is sugarcane waste which
accumulates in great quantities during
harvesting farmers often don't know what
to do with it
first the waste is dried
then charred
and processed into fertilizer
the name of our product here is saban
terra
and that means
to make the earth
new again
and here at tosunpo our goal is to
empower farmers to grow food organically
and also improve their soil health using
a more accessible and available
organic soil blend or input during
farming
workshops are held at the small model
farm next door 30 farmers belong to the
network
here they can learn about sustainable
farming
not just growing organic vegetables but
also that healthy soil is good for the
climate because it stores carbon
instead of burning
sugarcane waste product on the farm
we decided to
use it as organic blend which
helps improve the soil fertility so with
this aspect
i believe that as a farmer i have a
major role to play
which is fighting climate change this is
our main focus it's mainly farmers with
just a few hectares of land who
cultivate sugarcane in ghana they sell
the product at local markets it's often
used to make sweetener and alcohol
40 years ago sugarcane production was
still an important industry in ghana but
all of the bigger factories have since
closed down one of the principal reasons
was mismanagement audrius darko wanted
to find out more about it she
specialized in agricultural sciences and
decided to go talk to farmers directly
i realized that the culture was
different
they had been used to conventional
agriculture making use of a lot of
chemicals and how they planted how they
prepare their land burning crop residue
in the fields is also a common practice
despite people here feeling the effects
of climate change at first hand there's
been a change in the amount of rainfall
and harvests are diminishing the fires
put a big strain on the already severely
depleted soil
nature it's supposed to work with us
to better our lives but seeing us humans
degrading it on a daily by burning it by
destroying the biodiversity
and engaging in bad practices
that put put um
that put the fauna on the floor and in
extinction is is just frustrating for me
because we should be appreciative of
what nature gives us this community is
located directly on the avu lagoon an
important wetland
the canals are used to transport the
harvest and growing sugarcane itself
requires a lot of water
it's an area rich in biodiversity but
the use of chemicals in farming is
damaging the environment and there are
fewer and fewer fish
philip tomato and his father are
noticing that too
they own around five hectares of land
and have a big family to support
all the more reason for them to rethink
things
my fear is that if we continue applying
chemicals on our farmlands our children
will suffer
and they'll find it difficult to
cultivate sugarcane in the future
audrey starco occasionally takes a break
from the countryside for a trip to akra
in ghana cities urban farming is a new
trend hastened by the pandemic
audrey knows paulina from her university
days the software developer is one of
150 or so city dwellers who have their
organic fertilizer delivered to their
door
i plugged some seeds
and prepared across to you with that and
it was like amazing i plugged about
about 15 or so of them and professed you
with that end
i had that feeling that okay i am eating
something i planted like it was that
good
the countryside might be a world away
from the city but audrey starco enjoys
her new rural life
she's the only member of her team to
work full-time for the project which she
founded in 2018 together with other
students from the university of accra
they also developed the fertilizer in
the university lab
she wants many more farmers to become
aware of its benefits
it would transform their mindsets
about seeing waste as a resource
and giving them more knowledge and more
urgent zeal
to pass past this information to their
children and their grandchildren
andreas darko knows how to get her point
across and has gained the respect of the
farmers
now she just needs to find financial
backers in order for the savon sake
project to flourish in its full
potential
you